a little bit about me i did a master's
in psychology
uh i was studying computational
neuroscience
i got into pandas doing that i was
mostly writing python code and
not really working on computational
neuroscience
and then i started doing pandas and now
i'm working on blaze
at continuum and i do part-time
consulting as well at uh
at the sec okay
so is everybody familiar with numpy and
pandas
i hope so um so
who's come across a problem where they
get a big data set that's
or just bigger that can bigger than can
fit on their laptop
most people right so okay one person
um so they're limited to
to memory but they also have great apis
um and the goal of blaze is to
bring those apis into more complex
technologies like
amazon redshift hdfs piv those sorts of
things
so what's the approach that blaze takes
well it's an interface
it doesn't actually implement any
computation on its own
it doesn't replace databases or pandas
it sits on top of them
similar to a compiler for read-only
analytics
and like i said before it makes more it
makes complex technologies more
accessible
so how is it how does it fit into like
the pi data ecosystem
numpy and pandas have two layers there
they have an interface
which is what most people are probably
used to using
and they have some c code or python code
that implements their fast algorithms
so in blue i'm showing the sort of
interface layer and then the low level
code
the the
the uh so the rest of the world kind of
looks like this right
sql is a language on top of many
different implementations
and relational database management
systems um
you have no sql things like eight with
implementation being
[ __ ] h base and so forth and then you
have the numeric computing world
uh with things like hgf5 v calls
side eb and so forth and then you have
hadoop spark
where blaze is uh blaze is just an
interface
so it doesn't have any sort of low level
code it just says hey numpy do this hey
pandas do this hey spark do this
and sort of as i'm as i sort of
as i'm sure people have uh used these
libraries
various different libraries and like oh
how do i do a sum and spark how do i do
a group by and spark
and what blaze does is figures that out
for you
through uh through a couple of different
mechanisms
so the pieces of blaze are there's
basically two pieces
okay you have expressions and types
and you have little sort of recipes for
computing each type of expression
so here i'm showing basically
constructing a data frame
you make a symbol which is sort of a
symbolic expression
it has a couple of attributes and you
can sort of do things
you can compute over it so don't
hesitate to
interrupt me with questions happy to
answer those at any time
then when you want to actually evaluate
the expression you say compute
you give it an expression and you give
it the thing you want to compute over so
in this case i'm
using a data frame then i'm doing a list
of tuples and an nd array and so forth
i should also say i'm gonna be running
lots of live code against like three
different
uh master repos so
let's pray the demo gods
all right
so here's sort of a quick tour of uh of
sort of how how we use blaze
import a couple things uh blaze can work
with like a lot of different kinds of
data
right so i'm just sort of throwing an
integer in this in this container
and you can you can do things with it
when you look at the d
shape i want to make this a little
bigger
the d shape is a richer version of the d
type system
in numpy so it can express things like
missing values
uh nested data
and so forth and so you can you can do
things like that um
what you'll notice is that this is not
actually
a python type okay if you want to
actually get the python type you need to
call compute on it
um what these things are is just
building up basically an expression tree
you can work uh you can uh you know you
can work with different kinds of data
like lists
and we print things using using pandas
we sort of rip
out part of their pretty printing system
and you can evaluate expressions like
this okay and so you can get you can
also get the result type of
pretty much anything that blaze supports
we can work with tabular data sets they
don't have to be a data frame they can
be a list of lists or a list of tuples
in that case you need to specify the
fields
but again it sort of looks like a data
frame
let's say uh in this in this uh data
frame we want to get all the dead beats
the people who owe us money
um i'm gonna get we want to get their
name because we're gonna go like
i don't know ask for our money back so
we can do that
um this is a very very straightforward
operation uh
and blaze can sort of handle this
against different many different kinds
of data sets
you can also just straight up drive
pandas
but again i just sort of want to
emphasize the point that blaze is not
actually doing any work except
telling other systems to do the work
okay and so so you just
you can you can basically do the same
thing with uh
my scrolling ability okay with uh with
the data frame
again deadbeats
and so we get a series out of that so
one thing to keep in mind is that when
you actually call compute you'll
uh blaze will try hard to give you back
a type of object that's in the original
ecosystem that you're computing against
so if i'm in pandas land
i'm going to get back something from
pandas
you can also use things like sequel
alchemy tables
which sort of blaze expressions and
compute driving other another
system that has an expression system
and again you can run the same
computation but in this case
you get the generated sql back
rather than rather than some kind of
actually what you're getting back is uh
is a sequel alchemy object right so you
can
sort of it's this thing which doesn't
look like anything until you say print
um you can also just call str on it
we'll show you the sql
and let's uh this so here i'm connecting
to
a sqlite database looking at the iris
dataset which i'm sure most people are
familiar with
so you can do things like explore a
database which is kind of fun
right so i have this thing and i can
look at what databases i have in here
i have only one or what tables i have in
here so i have iris
looks like that can do things like sepal
length dot
mean gives you those kind of things
you can sort of generally explore things
in a very quick way and
without having to go through the sort of
annoying thing as setting up a you know
connection
then you got a whole execute you got to
build up your sql blazer
handles all of those annoying details
for you
it's a more complicated thing like a
group buy you can do those
and it's actually using whatever the
engine is sqlite
mysql postgres to do the computation
um you can also just get the table out
you don't have to actually get it from
the database
this is the same thing but getting out
just the table
once you have sql you might as well
start doing things like
talking to redshift okay so i'm going to
connect to a redshift cluster here
and now i have a redshift database which
is right here
and i can look at it's got the new york
city taxi trip data set which is going
to be
huge from the screen let's see
you know you can do things like i don't
know let's do a group buy on the
passenger account
and we'll say what's the average
trip time
trip time in
you can actually look at the sequel
before you do anything here
okay so this is a sequel we're going to
execute against redshift
alright so let's let's uh let's do that
another thing to note is that so nothing
actually executed here i just built up
the expression but
blaze overloads the underwrapper method
to
show the uh show the result of the
computation
when you when you print it in ipython so
hopefully this is fast redshift is
pretty fast
let's see i didn't i don't have like a
jeopardy song going okay sounds pretty
fast
it's like 175 million rows or something
like that
uh so there's some weird data in here
right there's 255 is not a valid
passenger count
neither is 129
does anybody use redshift
okay one person two people cool
so police can also talk to mongodb hdf5
hive anything that has a sql alchemy
dialect impala
okay so that's sort of the quick
overview
not so quick overview
blaze is also very easily pluggable uh
and i'm gonna show you guys something
has anyone heard of q or kdb
uh anyone not from continuum two people
so this is fun language by some
definition of fun
and here's some code examples of this
nice weird thing so you want to check
a string is a palindrome this is sort of
canonical cue and how you would write it
right it's really really hard to
to well do anything with
the way you print things to standard out
is by calling
by sort of calling a number as a
function
so when i first saw this this is sort of
my reaction
right like what are you talking about
how about one divided by cat
that's a thing in queue division is done
with module well percent sign
it converts each number to its ascii
representation and
does it vectorize uh computation so
that's fun
but how you know no no i don't i don't
want to deal with that
it's very very fast it's a column store
it's basically just sets
basically just a blob of bytes per file
with a tiny bit of information about the
type
uh and the name of the column
and the sec wanted to use it which they
already made this
technology choice before we got there so
but none of us wanted to write q so we
wanted to ditch it and keep but keep the
database
so i wrote a library called kdb pi which
uses blaze to translate translate python
into q
what's kdb well it's a database system
sold by kx
freit's free for 32-bit version download
on their website it's a column store
there's also there's a couple of other
formats you can you can do things in you
can partition
uh the columns on a particular date
it kind of makes things big things feel
small and huge things feel doable
and it's everywhere in the finance world
so kdp pi like i said it's a back end
for blaze it generates q code from
python
and then that's run by a queue
interpreter that's listening on a socket
so let's see what that looks like
so this is also running on the master
and
there's actually a few sort of uh memory
issues to work out here
because once you uh once you try to do
things
that don't fit in a 32-bit address space
it basically stops working and that's
because it's a free 32-bit version
all right so when you import that
actually hooks into
sql alchemy and registers the dialect
which allows me to write a c clock me
url and hook into the kdb database
right so it works in the same way that
the redshift
or at least it looks the same as a
redshift it's doing completely different
things
under the hood i have uh
two two tables in here uh from the new
york city taxi trip data set
i have trip and fair
oops same kind of thing fair has
essentially you know columns
okay that's not good i probably tried to
read too much into memory there
let's see
yeah it looks like it killed the gilded
process that's fun
all right let's restart the notebook
okay so let's go down here to something
again we have our fields so what's
what's actually sort of happening here
this is also using cqlocamy so
this is like some q code that's being
generated it's pretty bad
pretty gross looking but
it works well let's see if it works
this should be fairly quick
so the way so one thing that's kind of
interesting about kdb it has a symbol
type which lets you
store string like data in an efficient
manner
but its string processing is fairly it
leaves something to be desired
all right same kind of thing i take the
what am i doing
this is the average fare per per
medallion
okay there are way more than 10
medallions but blaze only shows you
the first 10 results
all right so that's that's uh that's kdb
pi sort of in the context of blaze
the point is is that you can hook into
this thing very easily
hook into blaze very easily
all right
so that does q and how does it compare
to say
something that's in the open source
world
okay so same data set
uh except we're comparing now against uh
the kdb data kb database and
blaze implemented a blaze back in the
sort of combines because pandas and
multi-processing
so it's a very very very simple
computations group by
on a couple of different columns and
then take the sum of
the trip time the trip distance so this
is sort of this is what it looks like
right you get your you write down your
expression uh
you take the trip time the average trip
time in seconds group by these columns
and uh yeah
i did it on a couple of different
machines i did on this laptop here
and then i did it on a machine where
everything could fit into memory
and so these are the results that are
now kind of hard to see let's see if i
can zoom in a bit
it doesn't look like i can zoom in okay
so one thing to sort of point out is
that i can
operate on this thing on my laptop like
i don't have to spin up the cluster
i don't have to spin up anything i can
just get the data on my laptop as long
as it fits on my hard drive
and then i can start doing things with
it
i also compared against panda's single
core on the big
big machine
and uh right so one thing to note is
that the string handling for
things in the pi data ecosystem are
somewhat lacking right so the the
passenger count is an integer column and
i can group by much faster on that than
i can the string column
with kdb that's not necessarily the case
the the integer column is actually
slightly slower
uh than the medallion column which is
this fancy symbol type
um okay so is this fair
uh i think it's pretty fair the way b
calls works is it splits each column
uh into a separate directory and then
each
each of those columns is split into
chunks that fit into cache
uh it's compressed and you can get
pretty decent compression
um i've seen 3x 4x it sort of depends on
the column if you have a bunch of
repeated strings
and you can get i mean i've seen up to
like 100x on particular columns
um kdb is not really clear how it's
doing things you can't really you can't
really look into that
um and then when you're
when you're creating your your tables
it's
a very very arduous process it takes a
really long time like to construct this
taxi trip data set took me a couple
hours
um whereas b calls you know it was csvs
to b calls which is fairly fast
you can read them in chunks using read
csv
and then dump into b calls
so i suspect if i did a comparison with
kdb
where the medallion and hack license
columns were strings
it would be much much slower than if i
used
its symbol symbol type
so what does blaze actually do
like i said it's b calls pandas
multiprocessing
and essentially what what it's doing is
multi-processing is splitting
uh this it's doing like a parallel map
operation and then reducing
in each process and then sort of joining
them all back together joining the
result back together
any questions so far
okay so about
30 minutes ago or maybe an hour ago i
packed up a graphlab integration
graph lab s frame
because the uh the gentleman from graph
lab
spoke to me and he was like hey let's uh
let's get blaze and s frames talking to
each other
so i got as far as it's got as far as
group by so let's see what happens
all right so it's uh it's import to
import graphlab
let's make some s frame that it's not
that useful
all right i already i already have uh
some blazings in here but let's say
we'll import data
we'll say data s frame
so now now we have blaze talking s
frames we can do things like
summing sorting
we can do group bys
okay so and this is all using native
graphlab s
frame things and i hacked this together
in
20 minutes maybe so so blaze is super
easy to plug into i can show you guys
implementation it's already sort of pr
on github
and of course it's failing that's nice
all right let's look at the file
so we got we have to to start talking to
graph lab is less than 100 lines of code
and i've got soaring group buys any
reduction that blade supports
type inference uh what else
binary operations
yeah i don't do joins yet but that
wouldn't be that hard uh
yeah so let's see any questions about
this
okay
looks like i'm only halfway through
so how does how does the how's the
actual chunking stuff work
well let's see
we take our we take our data set we
split it up
we operate with pandas on each chunk
evaluate those chunks
and currently the implementation assumes
that you've reduced those chunks
to something smaller than the original
chunk
and then we we aggregate those results
so just to see to see how the
implementation works here
suppose we have some huge array of
numbers like a trillion numbers
how do we compute the sum right we just
say x dot sum
with blaze you write down that
expression you give it its type which is
a trillion integers here
and then you write your expression so
nothing's actually been nothing's been
evaluated yet
if we're in a chunk we sort of do this
in
a very simple way right we get each
chunk
we take the sum of the chunks and we
take the sum of the sums
the way blaze does this is with a
function called split which gives you
a tuple of tuples of expressions for the
chunk
and expressions for the aggregate with
summing it's fairly straightforward
with counting it's a little less
straightforward but still pretty
straightforward the chunking expression
is count and then you want to sum those
counts at
when you aggregate
the average is even more complicated
still not too bad though
so we we need to keep track of two
things when we're computing chunks we
need to keep track of the sum and the
count
and then and then the aggregate
expression is taking the sum and then
dividing by the sum of the counts
we can do more complicated things like
group buys
we group we do group i in the chunk and
then we do a final group i at the very
very end
we can do pretty fancy things like the
variance of some
you know what is this ten thousand by
ten thousand by ten thousand
pair of points or uh point
in 2d space okay so we sort of have
little recipes that say oh how do i
compute the variance in chunks
and blaze will automatically figure this
out uh
if the if you sort of implement it if
you say hey use
chunks
and it works on a lot of things that
many people want to do with pandas
except starts and joins for the moment
but we have another library that's
sort of in the works called dasc and
we're probably going to ship the work
over to dasc
for this particular style computing
all right yeah
so right now it's just aggregates um you
the expression for each chunk has to be
the same
um but with uh with das which will
probably we'll probably actually just
rip out the the this sort of parallel
map
implementation and throw in das which is
a task scheduling library which will let
you do more complicated
uh computations
oh okay i already did that
and that's that's uh that's it for the
for the talk
there's the documentation for blaze
blaze.piedata.org
i'm going to be around until tomorrow
night so if anyone wants to chat or
ask questions that's it